شكرًا لك
[موسيقى]
كثيرًا
ألمادا
[موسيقى]
أجنبية
حدث شيئان مهمان جدًا
في العامين الماضيين
ولكنهما قادمان  لمدة 10 سنوات ،
كان أول شيء هو أن سوق الغاز الطبيعي المسال
أصبح شديد السيولة مع 400
شحنة اليوم على المياه المليئة بالغاز الطبيعي المسال
والتي يمكن أن تتفاعل بسرعة كبيرة مع مكالمة هاتفية ببساطة ،
لذا فقد جعلت السيولة الآن
المرونة ممكنة وستقرر الأسعار إلى
أين يتجه الغاز الطبيعي المسال
إذا وجدت نفسها في مأزق ،
فإنهم يرفعون أسعارهم
ويجتذبون الكمية الهائلة من الغاز الطبيعي المسال خلال
موسم الصيف. تتمتع أوروبا
بميزة وجود تخزين
لا تمتلك آسيا مخزونًا إذا كان الجو باردًا
في الشتاء.
الأسعار
أيضًا من أجل البدء في جذب الغاز الطبيعي
المسال وهذا ما سيحدث
الشيء الثاني المهم للغاية
هو أن الولايات المتحدة هي الآن 20 من سوق الغاز الطبيعي المسال
في طريقها لتصبح 30 بالمائة
من سوق الطاقة أصبح
مكانًا بالغ الأهمية للغاية
ويحدد الأسعار إلى حد ما على
الأقل مع الأرضية لأن ما
يحدث في الولايات المتحدة الآن له تأثير
على بقية العالم ، يمكنك ببساطة
إغلاق 20 سوقًا أو  30 في المائة
من السوق دون أن يكون لها
تأثير فوري على الأسعار ، لذا أصبحت الولايات المتحدة
الآن جزءًا لا يتجزأ من
سوق الطاقة العالمي ، فإن هذين
الأمرين يجعلان الأسعار الآن مهمة للغاية من
أجل جذب الغاز الطبيعي المسال
، ويناقش معظم الخبراء مخاوفهم من هذا
القادم.  شتاء
2022-2023 ولكن ماذا عن شتاء العام المقبل
2023 إلى 2024 هل
سنجد أنفسنا في وضع أسوأ ،
خاصة في
أوروبا ، سيعتمد بشكل كبير على ما إذا كان
ذلك بسبب وصول جميع الأخبار السارة
حول الغاز الطبيعي المسال في الوقت الحالي إلى جميع الغاز الطبيعي المسال.
هناك
أي جزيء يتم إنتاجه يتم
بيعه وهناك زيادة بطيئة جدًا على
مدى السنوات الأربع أو الخمس المقبلة إذا تم
قطعه بسرعة وإذا تمكنت
الولايات المتحدة من إيجاد طريقة
دعم سعة الغاز الطبيعي المسال الخاصة بهم ، فسوف
يستغرق الأمر من ست إلى سبع سنوات لتحقيق التوازن في
السوق على افتراض أن الطلب لا
يستمر في النمو ، وبالنظر إلى
أننا الآن نقيّد العرض ، فسوف نعاني من
بعض تدمير الطلب الذي
رأيته بالفعل في أوروبا.  حوالي
سبعة BCF للطلب تم
تدميرها بالفعل في الغالب من
الإنتاج الصناعي وسيكون هذا هو
الحال في السنوات القليلة المقبلة
، فلنتحدث عن الاستثمار الأمريكي في سعة الغاز الطبيعي المسال
، لم نشهد
استجابة الاستثمار بالتأكيد ليس هذا
العام في الولايات المتحدة.  في أه الخروج بسعة جديدة
للغاز الطبيعي المسال ،
لماذا تم
كتم الاستجابة من جانب الاستثمار ، لذلك
هناك مائة مليون طن من الغاز الطبيعي
المسال المسموح بها في الولايات المتحدة
ولكن لم يتم تمويلها بعد ، لذا فمن
الواضح أن نموذج العمل لدينا معطل
للتوصل إلى شيء مختلف
لجذب رأس المال إلى
سوق الغاز الطبيعي المسال في الولايات المتحدة الآن
الخبر السار هو أن هناك حوالي 50
مليون  التي هي قيد الإنشاء
الآن والتي ستأتي بين
25 26 27 والتي يجب أن تكون إضافة صغيرة
ولكن من أجل جعل 100 مليون
طن من السعة الإضافية تأتي إلى
السوق ، يتعين علينا إيجاد نموذج عمل مختلف ،
فإن الأساسيات
قوية للغاية اليوم LNG
والغاز الطبيعي في الولايات المتحدة يكلف
خمسة دولارات لتسييله في
عالم اليوم مع كل التضخم
وقضايا العرض ربما تكلف
خمسة دولارات أخرى ، لذلك ستكون
على المياه في خليج المكسيك في
مكان ما بين 10 و  12 دولارًا
ويمكنك بيع هذا الغاز الطبيعي المسال مقابل 25 30
35 لبقية العالم ، إنه
مربح للغاية ولكن الأسواق
المالية لم تستوعب ذلك ، لكن
الشيء الآخر الذي يمكنني قوله هو
أيام أسعار الغاز الطبيعي المسال بخمسة وستة دولارات.
من أجل تبرير مشروع جديد
في قطر في الولايات المتحدة أو في
أي مكان آخر في العالم ، فأنت بحاجة
إلى أن تزيد الأسعار بشكل كبير عن
12 إلى 15 دولارًا لتبرير
الاستثمار ولكن ليس أبدًا  يسعدنا
أننا نسمع ماكرو الرئيس الفرنسي
يشكو من أن حلفاءه في الولايات المتحدة
يبيعون فرنسا للغاز الطبيعي المسال
بسعر أربعة أضعاف ذلك الذي يتم بيعه
محليًا في الولايات المتحدة ، ما رأيك
في ذلك جيدًا للأسف في كل من
أوروبا وأوروبا  في الولايات المتحدة اليوم ،
نعاني من الأمية في مجال الطاقة ،
ولا نفهم كيف يعمل السوق
وخاصة الطبقة السياسية ،
لذلك لا توجد فكرة عن أن
الأمريكيين يرسلوننا بهذا السعر ، ولا
يوجد الأمريكيون هناك مجموعة من
المشاريع  التي تمتلكها وتطورها
شركات خاصة مختلفة تتبع
الأسعار ببساطة لفهم أن السوق
يجب أن يكون لديك استراتيجية للطاقة
إذا أراد الفرنسيون أو الألمان الاستفادة من
السعر الأمريكي بسعر التكلفة ،
فكل ما عليهم فعله هو القيام
بالاستثمار  في الولايات المتحدة ،
على عكس البلدان الأخرى ، أسواقنا
مفتوحة ، ويمكن لأي شخص إجراء استثمارات
في كل من احتياطيات التنقيب والإنتاج
والبنية التحتية هناك أربعة أو خمسة
مشاريع اليوم من شأنها أن تحدث فرقًا كبيرًا للغاية
في غضون خمس سنوات إذا
وجدوا استثماراتهم اليوم ، لذلك إذا كان
الرئيس ماكرون يريد الوصول إلى
الغاز الأمريكي بتكلفة الخمسة وخمسة
التي تحدثت عن 10 إلى 12 بشأن
المياه التي يتم تسليمها في مكان ما حوالي 12
إلى 13 إلى أوروبا ، كل ما يتعين عليهم فعله هو
العثور على أبطالهم الوطنيين
وتشجيعهم على الاستثمار في
سلسلة القيمة بالولايات المتحدة
في تلك المرحلة ،
لقد
رأينا المواجهة بين المملكة العربية السعودية وإدارة
بايدن الأمريكية بشأن أحدث تخفيضات
في أوبك.  بالإضافة إلى الإنتاج ، كيف تربط
ذلك باستراتيجية الطاقة ، لذا اسمحوا لي أن أبدأ
بهذا اليوم أسعار الغاز
أغلى من أسعار النفط على أساس محتوى وحدة حرارية بريطانية
أعتقد لأول مرة
في تاريخي أنني لم أر ذلك من
قبل ، فما الذي يحدث؟  الآن في
بلد مثل الجزائر والنرويج
بدلاً من حقن الغاز من أجل
إنتاج المزيد من النفط ، فإننا نجعل
إنتاج النفط يعاني من خلال بيع الغاز
مباشرة الذي سيأخذ النفط.  p
توقف الغاز وبدء الاستقرار في جميع
أشكال الطاقة هذه أزمة الطاقة
ليست كما كانت قبل 40 عامًا ، إنها في الحقيقة
أزمة طاقة وليست أزمة نفط وليست
أزمة غاز ، ستصبح جميع الطاقة
أكثر تكلفة بما في ذلك
مصادر الطاقة المتجددة لأن هناك طلبًا
لجميع أنواع الطاقة من جميع الأنواع المختلفة من
المصادر حتى قبل غزو
أوكرانيا ، لذا فإنك على هذا
الأساس تشهد نهجين مختلفين للغاية لدى
المملكة العربية السعودية
استراتيجية للطاقة وسياسة للطاقة ، فهم
مدروسون للغاية بشأن ما
يمكنهم فعله  خوفهم من
اختفاء الطاقة الإنتاجية الفائضة وليس
لديك القدرة على الرد الذي
سمعوه خلال الأشهر الثلاثة الماضية
أن العالم يدخل في ركود وأن
رد فعل كوفيد في الصين
يعيق نمو الطلب على النفط
كل شيء.  كنا نتوقع
أن يتقلص النفط الروسي
بسبب العقوبات لم يحدث بعد ، لذا
فهم ينظرون إلى الوضع الآن
مع دخول العالم في حالة ركود.
والقول إننا يجب أن نبني تلك السعة الفائضة
أه لأننا لا نستطيع تحمل
انهيار الأسعار تمامًا
على الجانب الآخر للأسف ليس
لدينا استراتيجية
في الولايات المتحدة لدينا ردود فعل غير متوقعة موقفًا
مختلفًا لذلك بدأنا
بمنع الحفر على  الأراضي الفيدرالية قبل عام
ونصف ، كان الأمر رمزيًا ، لم يكن
يعني أي شيء ، إنه مجرد رمز رمزي
، وبعد ذلك عندما رأينا أننا نحتاج بالفعل
إلى النفط ، يجب علينا تغييره
وقلنا لا ، كنا نمزح ، يمكنك المضي
قدمًا والحفر مرة أخرى.
لا أفهم بعد أساسيات
واقتصاديات ما يلزم
للتنقيب في الولايات المتحدة وهو
هدف متحرك أه كل الإنتاج في
الولايات المتحدة يعاني بنفس الطريقة التي يعاني بها
باقي العالم من التضخم
من أه قيود سلسلة التوريد و
من معدلات الفائدة المرتفعة ، عليك أن
تأخذ كل هذا في الاعتبار
وعليك أن تسأل نفسك ما إذا كنت قد حددت أرضية
68 أو 70 دولارًا التي أقوم من خلالها بتجديد
spr الخاص بي ، فهذا يكفي لتشجيع
الشركات الأمريكية  es للتدريب وهو
عمل مستمر وقد يكون كافياً اليوم
ولكن ليس غدًا ، لذا عليك أن تفعل هذا ،
يجب أن يكون لديك استراتيجية للطاقة
وعليك تنفيذها مع وضع أهداف طويلة الأجل
في الاعتبار إذا كنت تبحث فقط عن
المدى القصير-  عواقب المصطلح مع ارتفاع
أسعار البنزين أو انخفاضها أو أنها ليست
استراتيجية ،
فنحن في الولايات المتحدة لدينا
سيارة مبيعًا هي F-150 التي تصل إلى
16 ميلاً إلى المدفع ، نصف ما
قد يستغرقه الجلوس العادي من حيث
استهلاك البنزين
نحن نهدر مواردنا لأنه
ليس لدينا استراتيجية
سان أنطونيو
أسئلة
[موسيقى]
أجنبي
أجنبي أجنبي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
أجنبي
[تصفيق]
حسنًا أنا لست وزير الطاقة ولكن
سأخبرك في آخر شرطي  التي
حضرها رئيس الوزراء الموقر
، قدمت الهند بعض الالتزامات بعيدة المدى
للغاية ، والتزامات طموحة وشاملة
بشأن ما يتعين علينا القيام به على
صعيد المناخ ، ويسعدني جدًا أن
أبلغكم بأننا نسرع ​​في
التنفيذ.  من بين جميع التزاماتنا ،
ولكن أكثر من ذلك ، فإن قطاعنا الخاص بشكل
فردي يتوصل إلى
الأهداف والالتزامات على أه أنت تعرف
Net Zero الشركات نفسها
التي تتقدم كثيرًا على ما
تلتزم به الحكومة في بعض النواحي ، إنه
أسهل بالنسبة لهم  لكن على الحكومة
أن تتحمل المسؤولية الشاملة ، أنا
سعيد جدًا لأن هذا الاجتماع أه
لأديبك ينعقد قبل أسبوع أو نحو ذلك
من اجتماع الشرطي القادم ، كما
يسعدني جدًا أن أجد أن الشرطي
العام القادم سيعقد في الإمارات العربية المتحدة.
أعتقد أن المجتمع العالمي
لا يتجمع ليس فقط في سياق
تغير المناخ واجتماعات الشرطي ولكن
أيضًا المناقشات حول الطاقة التي تعد
عنصرًا حاسمًا في ذلك للعمل
نحو
الالتزام الذي نتعهد به ليس فقط
لجيلنا ولكن للجيل القادم
في ضمان  أن موارد الأرض
محفوظة لصالح
البشرية وأيضًا للجيل القادم
يعتمد المورد للهند على
حالة السوق حتى 31 مارك  ح 2022
استحوذت روسيا على 0.2 في المائة فقط من
واردات الهند من الطاقة إذا كنت ستصبح
طالبًا في الإحصاء ، فسيتم تسميتها
D minimis ولن تظهر في
الإحصاءات أنها منخفضة جدًا ولكن هذا ليس
شيئًا حدث كطالب  نتيجة
24 فبراير ولكن كان هناك
تغيير ديناميكي في الوضع أه
في الأشهر من أبريل مايو يونيو من هذا
العام
زادت واردات النفط الروسي وازدادت
لأنه كان متاحًا اليوم العراق أعتقد أنه
أكبر مورد للطاقم للهند
و  تقليديا كان الأمر مع المملكة
العربية السعودية UA مرتفع للغاية ولكن الهند تدين
بمسؤولية أخلاقية لمواطنها
علينا أن نضمن أن الطاقة ليست متاحة فقط
ولكنها متاحة بأسعار معقولة
ويمكنني أن أخبرك أن الهند ستشتري
من أي مكان تريده وبقدر ما
قلق بشأن سقف السعر المقترح ، لقد
سمعت أن النفط الذي سيأتي
من روسيا إلى المجر سيتم
إعفاءه من النفط الذي كان متجهًا من روسيا
إلى الصين عبر خط الأنابيب ، معفى من
اليابان.  a معفى لذلك سنقوم بدراسة هذا الأمر
سنحاول معرفة من الذي يستهدفه الحد الأقصى للسعر
ولكن إذا كنا واثقين تمامًا
من اتخاذ قرار في مصلحتنا الوطنية الخاصة
[موسيقى]